APPOINTMENT OF A NEW SPECIAL
COUNSEL TO INVESTIGATE CIVIL
LIBERTIES BY THE DOJ AND THE
FBI.
MORE ON THAT IN A MINUTE.
FIRST, SAM NUNBERG WENT ON
TELEVISION AND THE NEWS WORLD
GROUND TO A HALT.
NOTHING ELSE HAPPENED.
AMERICANS STOPPED DYING OF DRUG
ODs, THE BORDERS WERE SECURE.
MOST OF THE DAY, ALL THAT
MATTERS IS SAM NUNBERG.
WATCH.
>> GOOD EVENING.
I'M ERIN BURNETT.
BREAKING NEWS.
DEFINED AND SPEAKING OUT,
TRUMP'S FORMER CAMPAIGN AIDE SAM
NUNBERG REFUSING TO COMPLY WITH
A GRAND JURY SUBPOENA IN THE
RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION.
>> THIS IS NOT WHAT THE WHITE
HOUSE WANTED TO HEAR.
WHAT DOES HE KNOW?
>> A FORMER TRUMP CAMPAIGN AIDE
WHO SAID HE WAS SUBPOENAED.
>> THE HISTORY OF AMERICAN NEWS
MEDIA WE HAVE NEVER WITNESSED
ANYTHING LIKE THIS.
>> WHO WRITES NEWS COPY?
RUSSIAN BOTS.
SAM NUNBERG SPEAKING OUT.
WHO IS SAM NUNBERG?
YESTERDAY HE WAS A PRETTY
OBSCURE PART TIME POLITICAL
CONSULTANT FROM NEW YORK CITY
WHO HAS BEEN STRUGGLING WITH A
SUBSTANCE ABUSE PROBLEM.
HE'S A NICE GUY, BUT YOU HAVE
PROBABLY NEVER HEARD OF HIM.
NOW PEOPLE ARE TELLING YOU THAT
HE COULD BE THE JOHN DEAN OF THE
SCANDAL.
HE WAS NOWHERE NEAR THE
DECISIONS WHEN THEY WERE MADE.
HE WORKED AT THE LOW LEVEL OF
THE CAMPAIGN.
HE LEFT 1 1/2 YEARS BEFORE THE
ELECTION.
IF THERE WAS A RUSSIA
CONSPIRACY, SAM NUNBERG WOULDN'T
KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
MORE LIKELY WHAT WAS GOING ON
YESTERDAY, NUNBERG BRILLIANTLY
PLAYED THE PRESS.
TURNS OUT THIS FRIDAY HE'S
TALKING TO ROBERT MUELLER'S
INVESTIGATORS WHICH IS ANOTHER
MEASURE OF HOW ABSURD THIS
INDEPENDENT COUNSEL
INVESTIGATION IS.
OTHERS HAVE BEEN CHARGED WITH
PERJURY AFTER DOING INTERVIEWS
WITH MUELLER'S INVESTIGATORS.
NUNBERG WON'T BE.
WHY?
HE JUST ADMITTED IN PUBLIC TO
BEING A ALCOHOLIC AND ACTED LIKE
A LUNATIC ON TELEVISION FOR
HOURS.
IT'S THE PERFECT PREEMPTIVE
INSANITY DEFENSE.
MUELLER CAN'T INDICT HIM.
AFTER YESTERDAY, NO JURY WOULD
CONVICT SAM NUNBERG.
WAS THAT HIS PLAN?
WE DON'T KNOW REALLY.
IF IT WAS, NONE OF THE PEOPLE
INTERVIEWING HIM YESTERDAY WOULD
HAVE FIGURED OUT.
THERE'S NOBODY DUMBER THAN AT
CNN AND MSNBC.
HOW DUMB?
DUMB ENOUGH TO SEE RUSSIAN
SABOTEURS UNDER EVERY BED.
RUSSIAN HAS WANING POWER ON THE
WORLD STAGE.
ONE MILITARY BASE OUT SIDES ITS
BORDERS.
THE IMAGINARY RUSSIA, THE ONE
YOU SEE ON TELEVISION, HAS NEVER
BEEN MORE POWERFUL.
THE DNC AND NBC NEWS, PUTIN IS
DIABOLICAL AND OMNIPOTENT.
HE EMPOWERED THE NRA.
HAND PICKED SAM NUNBERG AND
CARTER PAGE TO UNDERMINE OUR
DEMOCRACY.
IT'S DELUSIONAL.
THEY BELIEVE IT.
MEANWHILE, BACK IN THE REAL
WORLD, EVIDENCE MOUNTS THAT THE
ACTUAL PROBLEM IS NOT THE
RUSSIANS OR VLADIMIR PUTIN, IT'S
THE CORRUPT AND DECADENT
RESOLUTELY STUPID LEADERSHIP OF
OUR OWN ELITES.
THAT'S WHY TRUMP GOT ELECTED.
IN REACTION TO THEM.
THAT'S WHY THE EUROPEAN UNION IS
ABOUT TO COLLAPSE.
JUST THIS WEEKEND IN ITALY, THE
RULING PARTY WAS CRUSHED WHILE
ANTI-ESTABLISHMENT CANDIDATES
WON BIG.
POLLS SHOW THAT PEOPLE ARE
UNHAPPY WITH ECONOMIC POLICY.
THEY HATED THE IMMIGRATION
POLICIES THAT HAVE CRUSHED THEIR
NATIONAL CULTURE UNDER WAVES OF
MIGRANTS.
SOUNDS FAMILIAR?
THERE AS HERE, THE ELITES HAVE
FAILED.
THEY CAN'T ADMIT THAT.
THEY CAN'T FACE THEIR OWN
FAILURE.
SO THEY BLAME RUSSIA.
SAMANTHA POWER SAID THAT.
RUSSIAN WON THE ITALIAN
ELECTION, SHE EXPLAINED.
MAYBE SAMANTHA POWER AND HER
FRIENDS AT MSNBC AND THE REST
HAVE NO CHOICE BUT TO KEEP
PRETENDING.
THE FAR RULING CLASS ADMITTED
THE TRUTH ABOUT RUSSIA, THEY
WOULD HAVE TO TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THEIR
FAILURES, AND THEY WON'T.
CHRISSY SETZER JOINS US.
THIS ITALIAN THING HAPPENED.
IT'S ANOTHER DOMINO THAT IS
LEADING CLEARLY TOWARD THE
DISSOLUTION OF THE EUROPEAN
UNION.
RUSSIA DID THAT?
>> IT'S POSSIBLE THEY PLAYED A
ROLE.
IT'S POSSIBLE.
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN -- THESE TWO
THINGS CAN BE TRUE AT THE SAME
TIME.
ONE, IT CAN BE TRUE THAT
ORGANICALLY INDEPENDENTLY WE ARE
SEEING ACROSS THE GLOBE THESE
MOVEMENTS THAT ARE POPULOUS,
ANTI-IMMIGRANT.
ALSO IT BEING TRUE THAT RUSSIA
IS STIRRING THE POT, WE HAVE
FOUND OUT THAT RUSSIAN TROLL
FARM WAS SPENDING A MILLION
DOLLARS A MONTH IN 2016 IN THE
U.S. ELECTIONS TO, AGAIN, STIR
THE POT, TO INFLUENCE OUR
ELECTIONS BY --
>> Tucker: IN THE DEMOCRATS
SPEND -- WAIT.
I'M NOT SAYING RUSSIA IS NOT
DESTABILIZING THE UNITED STATES.
I'M SAYING IT'S IRRELEVANT.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE POLL NUMBERS,
PEOPLE ARE DISSATISFIED WITH THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE PEOPLE IN
CHARGE.
THAT'S WHY TRUMP GOT ELECTED.
THAT'S WHY BREXIT HAPPENED.
THAT'S WHY SCANDINAVIA IS ABOUT
TO TURN.
IN EACH ONE OF THESE CASES, THE
ELITES RATHER THAN ACCEPTING
RESPONSIBILITY BLAME IT ON A
FOREIGN HAND.
YOU DON'T SEE A THREAD HERE?
>> I THINK BOTH THINGS CAN BE
TRUE.
IT'S TRUE ON ONE HAND THAT THERE
WAS UNREST AMONG THE COUNTRY
THAT WAS UNHAPPY WITH THE
LEADERS THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
GIVEN THE LAST DECADE, COUPLE
DECADES.
AT THE SAME TIME, IT'S ALSO TRUE
THAT RUSSIA HAS BEEN GROOMING
DONALD TRUMP FOR YEARS.
THAT'S WHAT THE STEELE DOSSIER
SAYS.
>> Tucker: HOLD ON.
I DON'T THINK IT'S FAIR OR
HONEST TO SAY THE ALLEGATION IS
RUSSIA IS JUST HELPING POPULOUS
OR RIGHT WING MOVEMENTS.
THE CLAIM IS ALSO THAT THE
RUSSIANS ARE HELPING BERNIE
SANDERS.
RIGHT?
AND THEY WERE HELPING JILL
STEIN.
>> THEY WERE HAPPENING
ANTI-HILLARY CLINTON.
>> Tucker: THEY ARE PAYING FOR
THE MOST LEFT WING CABLE STATION
THERE IS, RT.
>> A PRO RUSSIA STATION.
NOT NECESSARILY LEFT WING.
>> Tucker: MAYBE THE OBVIOUS IS
TRUE.
THE MORNING SHOWS ON MSNBC, THE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN MAKING
POLICY HAVEN'T TAKEN INTO
ACCOUNT THE VIEWS OF VOTERS AND
VOTERS ARE MAD ABOUT THAT.
SO RATHER THAN LEARN SOMETHING
FROM WHAT IS HAPPENING, THEY'RE
BLAMING FORCES THAT AREN'T
THERE, THE RUSSIANS.
>> THE RUSSIAN FORCES ARE IN
FACT THERE.
I THINK ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS
LISTEN TO NOT JUST SAMANTHA
POWER, YOU CAN LISTEN TO ANY ONE
OF -- YOU CAN LISTEN TO OUR OWN
SECRETARY OF STATE.
YOU CAN LISTEN TO REX
TILLERSON --
>> Tucker: I DON'T CARE.
NONE OF THOSE PEOPLE IS WISE
BEGINNING WITH SAN -- SO MAN
THAT POWERS WHO FOREIGN POLICY
HAS LEFT THE REGION IN TATTERS.
SHE SAYS THAT DEMOCRATIC VOTERS
ARE REACTING AGAINST.
SO DO YOU THINK THERE'S ANY
COINCIDENCE THAT THE RUSSIA HOAX
IS BEING USED TO DISCREDIT NOT
ANYBODY ON THE RIGHT BUT ANYBODY
THAT CHALLENGES POWER.
YOU NOTICE THAT?
>> I DISAGREE CALLING IT A
OF WHAT THE HOAX WERE, IT WENT
BACK TO WELL-BEFORE THE 2016
ELECTION.
THAT'S WHEN WE FIRST LEARNED
ABOUT IT.
YOU MAY REMEMBER FROM ONE OF THE
DEBATES WITH HILLARY CLINTON
WHEN SHE TALKED ABOUT 17
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES THAT HAVE
CONCLUDED THAT RUSSIA HAS BEEN
TRYING TO MEDDLE, INFLUENCE THE
INU.S. --
>> Tucker: NO EVIDENCE HAS
EMERGED FROM THAT DATE TILL NOW
THAT ITS REAL.
I WANT YOU TO THINK ABOUT
SOMETHING WRITTEN IN ROLLING
STONE TODAY BY A LEFT WING
WRITER, THIS IS SOMEONE THAT
HATES TRUMP.
A FULL-ON LEFTY.
SAID THIS "BY AN AMAZING
COINCIDENCE, ALL OF THE
CANDIDATES THAT TERRIFIED THE
POLITICAL STATUS HAVE TALKED
ABOUT COVERT RUSSIAN
DESTABILIZATION INITIATIVES RUN
BY PUTIN."
IT'S NOT CLEAR TO YOU THIS IS A
REACTION ABOUT VOTERS WHO ARE
MAD BECAUSE NOTHING IS WORKING
FOR THEM AND RATHER THAN LISTEN
TO THEM, THE ELITES ARE LIKE OH,
IT'S NOT OUR FAULT.
IT'SPY
IT'SP
IT'SPY  -- IT'S PUTIN'S FAULT?
>> I --
>> Tucker: I'M AMAZED SOMEONE AS
SMART AS YOU.
MAYBE THE CLAIMS ARE
DEFENSELESS.